whoa this is such an honor thank you so
much I want to say a huge things I'm
gonna open my paper because I'm so
nervous I want to say a huge thank you
to the Academy for choosing my film
because it's an extremely hard film to
watch it's about a huge humanitarian
catastrophe that is taking place in my
home in Greece it's about the refugee
crisis and you know some people think
that Greece is far away Syria is far
away the war is far away and it's tough
images and it's kind of sometimes easier
for for all of us to turn our head away
so I want to also thank somebody who is
not turning his head away it's the main
character of my film kiriakos
Papadopoulos unfortunately he's not here
he is a captain on a Greek coast guard
vessel and he's been saving life after
life after life in this visceral crisis
that's still going on so it's been a
huge honor for me that he let me into
his life and he let me make this story
and show this story the way it actually
is happening I also want to thank
obviously my school the journalism
school of the University of
california-berkeley
Orlando Bagwell dan Krauss John ELLs
picnics
James pace corn silk who was with me in
the treatment aetna Nelson and David
echoes Wolf Ridge that wrote the music
for my film and everyone of course who
believed that this is an important story
that needs to be told thank you so much